in Sweden a children's program this is a
children's program is being criticized
for teaching kids about their bodies by
showing a cartoon that features dancing
genitals
yes it's called snoppen ah snippin i'm
not making this up i couldn't make this
up this is totally real
[Music]
baby do
oh my god that is so it's I just found
that to be crazy is this kind of
disgusting it might work in Sweden it
seems inappropriate here though yeah I
was also offended because I think they
must watch our show I thought that penis
looked a lot like me I really do John is
totally me look like the people I'm just
yours are we even able to show this
maybe gonna check first we should have
checked I didn't check it we can even
check Jeff I'm just curious can we show
that is the TBS standards guy here yeah
Karl Waxler Karl West oh yeah hey Karl
are you here can we show this clip
huh can we show the clip you're good
okay thanks a lot
[Music]
strange that he would be the standards
guy here's very strange indeed and very
ironical even yeah
you